Hi, I'm Tim Robinson.
You might remember me from
SNL and Detroiters.
I'm proud to announce
my new sketch comedy show,
I Think You Should Leave,
is coming to Netflix.
In this show,
people get a little embarrassed
and then very angry.
And the guest stars include Cecily Strong,
Will Forte, Sam Richardson,
Patti Harrison, Tim Heidecker
and many, many more.
But inside...
I am actually really, really sad.
And I use comedy as a tool
to fight the resentment
I have towards my dad.
My dad and I didn't have
a good relationship
because he was nasty to me.
But I showed him.
I learned how to have a show
where people get
a little embarrassed
and then very, very angry.
Where the guest stars include
Fred Willard,
Vanessa Bayer, Andy Samberg,
Kate Berlant and many, many more.
Hey, buddy! I got your hoagie.
Dad, I didn't ask you for a hoagie, did I?
I asked you...
for an onion sandwich
with chicken pepper bread.
Oh, sorry, pal.
I love you, son.
I love you too, Dad,
and I'm very proud of ya!
And the man I've become?
And the man you've become.
Now go get me an onion sandwich
with chicken pepper bread.
You fuckin' idiot.
I guess I just believe
everybody in this world's
got a little bit of good in them.
And a little bit of bad.
That's probably why I...
sometimes wear this Yin-Yang necklace.